[Music]
frequently when you look at a problem
you may have questions about various
groupings within your data for example
is there a difference between new staff
members versus experienced staff do we
see a difference between shifts or by
clinical training nurse vs physician
versus paramedic this desire to look at
the population as various subgroups is
called stratification by stratifying
your data you may be able to identify
opportunities for improvement that
aren't obvious from data as a whole I
worked with a group of pharmacists that
we're trying to improve the process
known as medication reconciliation in
hospital medication reconciliation is
the process of creating the most
accurate list possible of all
medications a patient is taking and
comparing that list against the
physicians orders the goal is to provide
correct medications to the patient at
all transition points than the hospital
as the pharmacists were discussing the
process they quickly identify different
scenarios within the process worthy of
stratifying including day versus night
and weekday versus weekend it was
predicted there were variations in the
process in these areas that would be
worth understanding so let's take a look
at an example of that data let's imagine
that their prediction came true so if we
were going to draw ourselves a little
bit of a run chart and we come down here
and imagine we had our days of the week
right so we have monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday saturday
sunday monday tuesday wednesday thursday
friday saturday sunday right so we've
got two weeks here and imagine we're
coming along and we're plotting our data
and on Monday and Tuesday you know the
data is kind of right here natural
variation but then all of a sudden we
look up and on the weekend we have a
change in our data points that seem
really different it's almost like
there's a different system that's
occurring on the weekends right these
these are
samples here are a different system than
the ones down here below and so this is
a very common example of where you might
look at a place where it makes sense to
stratify out the the two different parts
of the week because you're seeing that
there are different systems that exist
another common example is to create a
small multiples display of measures for
example imagine we're thinking about
hand washing right so we may want to
look at our data overall and have a run
chart that tells us about our overall
data alright so overall but we may have
a prediction that there's some variation
across our different sites and so we
might have several different places that
we're looking at and we'll just calm
like a b c d and e and we'll stratify
those those individual units out or
places so that we can look at their data
and see is there variation that exists
across sites and the stratification
helps us potentially see where there's
opportunity for improvement that will
help change our outcome so by doing this
it enables us to be able to see where
there's variation in the system right
when you think about your work what are
some of the obvious stratification
opportunities you see that might help
you learn more about your process
you